right here straight ahead it's a family
affair for travis scott
kylie jenner and their daughter stormi i
love it
the family of three stepped out tuesday
night in new york city to attend the
72nd annual parsons benefit
at pier 17 where travis was being
honored
check out the dashing couple looking
chic in their high fashion ensembles
but let's give credit where it's due
stormy is totally stealing the spotlight
here
rocking her elegant black dress and high
top sneakers
[Applause]
and get this during the rapper's speech
at the event he made sure to give his
leading ladies a proper
shout out according to e travis gushed
quote
stormy i love you and wifey i love you
and let's not get it twisted prior to
hitting the red carpet
kylie gave fans a peek inside her glam
sesh getting ready
the 23 year old mogul took to her
instagram story to share this selfie she
snapped in a towel
and this video being sewn into her
vintage jean-paul gautier dress
it's fun the trio has been spending a
lot of time together recently
earlier this month travis and stormy
ganged up on mama kylie during an
epic water balloon fight
what and last month the proud parents
took their daughter to the happiest
place on earth
disneyland they also jetted off to miami
to celebrate the rapper's
29th birthday as for the status of kylie
and travis's relationship
a source recently told et that the pair
who started dating in 2017 and have been
on and off ever since are trying to make
things work
quote travis really respects kylie and
worships the ground she walks on
she means a lot to him he loves that
kylie is such a boss and how great of a
mom she is
when it comes to kylie the source says
she especially loves that travis makes a
big effort to be involved in their
daughter's life
explaining quote kylie would love to
have more kids one day
and she would of course love for the
father of her future children to be
travis although the source adds that the
two aren't rushing
and are seeing where things go baby
okay moving on